العدسات اللاصقه المنتج المستهلك بقوه
والمطلوب دائما من قبل الملايين حول العام
العالم اما طبعا لغرض طبي او تجميلي خبر
صادم لمستخدمي العدسات مختبر طبي معتمد في
الولايات المتحده توصل الى وجود مواد
مسرطنه في 18 علامه تجاريه شهيره من
العدسات طبعا مضموننا دراسه مشاهدينا
توصلنا انه العديد من العدسات اللاصقات
تصنع من مواد كيماويه ابديه تدخل وتستقر
في العين ولا تتحلل بسهوله ابدا ولذا هي
ابديه بل وكميات اعلى بخمسين الف مره من
المستويات التي تعتبر امنه تلك التي قد
تسبب مع مرور الزمن مشكلات صحيه بما في
ذلك السرطان ايضا امراض الكبد الكلى اضافه
الى اضطرابات المناعه الذاتيه ومشاكل
الخصوبه
دكتور يعني هذا خبر صادم بانه العدسات قد
تسبب امراض حتى يعني
العدسات الطبيه ايضا صح هي فعليا العدسات
الطبيه هي المشكله كانت طبيه او كانت
ملونه هذا اللي للاسف كما قلت برهن العلم
انه في ممكن يكون الها مدار على المدى
الطويل
ومدارها ما كنا مكتشفينه قبل وحاليا صار
في هاي الدراسه في جريده الجارديان لبرهنت
انه هناك ماده اسمها
تستعمل وممكن تسبب هذه الامراض على المضى
الطويل
دكتور كل العدسات اللاصقه يعني من كل
الماركات فيها هاي الماده لانه معروف بانه
هاي العدسات مصنوعه من مواد حيويه يتقبلها
الجسم مثل السيليكون مثلا صحي مصنوعه من
السيليكون مواد طبيعيه جدا بس يتم الاضافه
للسيليكون والهيدروجين ماده اسمها
تخلي هذه العدسه تكون سوفت او لينه على
العين بما انه هذه الماده ضروريه تضاف الى
كل انواع العدسات ان كانت ملونه او غير
ملونه كل الماركات بيستعملها كل الماركات
تستعمل
وبالدراسه اجريت على 18 نوع من انواع
العدسات وتبين انه بكل هالانواع الموجوده
في السوق حاليا موجوده هذه الماده
الفليورين والفليورين ممكن يمتصها جسم او
تمتصها العين طبعا مش من لبسها مره او خمس
مرات انه تعمل اضرار اي العدسات افضل هل
هي التي تغير بشكل يومي هي التي تستمر
اسبوعيا ام شهريا هلا طبعا التي تستعمل
يوميا هي الافضل من الاسبوعين افضل من
الشهري اقل اقل مخ اقل مخاطر بس بالنسبه
لماده الفليورين للاسف موجوده بثلاث انواع
ان كانت يوميه او ان كانت اسبوعيه او ان
كانت شهريه اليوميه هي افضل بالنسبه
للالتهابات انما تشكل الالتهابات على
العيون التهابات بكتيريه انما الفيوريين
موجود بهذه ثلاث انواع ومن هون النصيحه
انه تخفيض الوقت اللبس بالنسبه للعدسات ما
نكون عن نلبسها مثلا ننام فيها مثلا نام
بعدسه هذا اكبر خطا هذا شيء جدا يعني بكفي
انه نشيلها مثلا بالليل بنكون خفضنا على
الاقل عشر ساعات في اليوم رقم اثنين
نلبسها فقط عند المناسبات الضروريه ورقم
ثلاثه نتكلم انه ممكن ناخذ اتجاه اخر انه
النظاره هلا طبعا النظاره ممكن اشخاص يقول
لك انا ما تناسبني وخاصه بطبيعه عملي كان
مقدم برامج او تقنيات لتصحيح النظر اللي
هي صارت حاليا اامن من العدسات بمئه مره
لانه نسبه الالتهابات مثلا في العدسات
واحد بالمئه واحد من عشره الاف كنا عم
نتكلم عن الطائرات صار الليزك امن من
الطائرات حاليا يعني ممكن تخسر نظر باللي
غير موجود مثلا